These are not the ways to treat us,
minister,
and we demand respect.
That is why I record
of my retirement
and perhaps the entire bench in this discussion.
Given the statements of the Minister of Health,
Guillermo Jaramillo the night before,
I record that my participation and voting
on health reform
and the other reforms I have made with criteria
independence.
I even announced last week
publicly
my negative vote for this health reform,
indicating what he had valuable
and indicating why I was turning away from it.
I wanted to,
Mr. President,
leave not only a written record,
but also public,
in order to express the discomfort
and say publicly that I have requested,
along with other congressmen,
to the party for us to give the discussion
once and for all,
to really evaluate being an independence party,
as some of us have felt and been acting.
Thank you,
President